and sorry hello and welcome to this
video damn jeno for ya played him very
recently and gave him a full point with
the mouse lip let's try to avoid this in
this game b6 I actually think that this
is not good him and cause of reform
taking first I think if I first and then
Bishop d3 I believe it it's supposed to
be not ok for black but yeah don't ask
me about the the details and the night
only for is slightly unstable and then
everything costs quite a bit of time
here
97 who yeah okay I can take just take
the five here or not yeah I think I
think I'll do that c if c for now as
possible then maybe let's just play in
the most direct way and black hands to
play c6 this position is strategically
rather rather compromised yeah I kept
them so I'm going for that so i can go
Bishop e3 I can go a form a force them
this is a very decent way of doing
things shooting for 85 the only thing I
don't like is like rook c8 at c3 is
somewhat weak
you
Bishop e3 is also not bad but not
entirely sure yeah I think I go with the
a porn I'm not sure either said but that
in for a five is normally a good plan
here okay but where to go maybe even he
i am A five looks good and 93 it's not
not really helping him a lot I'm okay
with the queen bee three or queen bee
for something like that okay so he
doesn't care so much about a five
happening you see doing no I don't think
I'd f6 I mean I'm threatening to take on
b6 now him threatening no I mean
threatening is a strong word but I will
do that let's say I just realized 93's
nonsense anyway as h7s hanging there's
probably rather important little point
okay so here I'm just taking I guess
you
okay so this should be five I would like
to play with this Knight c3 an
interesting possibilities also just
Bishop e3 as a good move right develop
this and threatening to take on e4 and
then 95 that would just win the pawn
essentially well and developing this all
somebody not a bad idea now went then
okay I can still do what I had what I
said earlier shoot for this window the
pawn f5 couldn't be three loses
everything so he will lose the porn at
least I don't see how he saves it and
the thing is it's also there is a big
square on d6 maybe you can play like 9p
694 takes takes 95 yeah it seems his
he's going for that he also might have
Queen to d5 interesting anyway I think I
have to check now
25mm okay i have f 3 that's not a huge
issue or somewhere else yeah i think
here to cavity for well it's not easy
here as and the night on c4 is covering
this six I have Knight c3 though and
then d five maybe yeah let's support
this with night scene that tech 93 moon
oh it's not reacting to it okay
d Phi don't get it looks like a piece
here
I am i overlooking something I don't see
I don't see anything great for him okay
how to play here and check the beep on
let's block the pawn and please no more
slips in the earlier gamer also was just
a piece up for nothing
maybe I can just go up to five and win
that porn okay let's make sure back rank
is not getting a problem
yeah it looks very okay don't see any
coming to play threatening also group c
5 he's playing for the mall slip it
really is in after my last after that
last game i understand what he's doing
here okay so check here I guess chan
bishop t4
check-check
don't see a major resign Queen f7 Queen
f7 is not exactly complicated can okay
so Jim I'm thinking pretty how pretty
happy with this then I think this line
is better for white it just better for
while I think yeah the engine agrees
gives might almost a pawn here ya think
black it cannot black has no one really
hold on e4 and he will lose time lose
the bishop pair things like that
whatever it is it's not good and I think
he probably see five is better after
this this and this it looks pretty bad
because after c6 this position is
strategically almost losing this kind of
this kind of position is very bad
because i have a4 a5 here and this will
create further weaknesses the d5 point
is week already and after a four a five
there will be a week be or a pawn plus i
have the two bishops and very good
control his night from the 75 sample is
also pretty bad so it's it's a very nice
position in a form yeah rookie age and
now I five him it's the engine is
constantly like on plus 1 and tier
Bishop e3 just support the center yeah
and now this is an interesting decision
that Bishop takes before I wanted to
cash in in some some kind of way but
move like Luke c1 is also excellent
maybe it's even better and threatening
Bishop b5 now and he cannot really
prevent that I had some animals this is
this is good for Wyatt still but not as
good as rook see one here he gets he
gets some kind of activity night c4 is a
bit better
it seems yeah I've got the porn but he's
got activity especially with this Bishop
mmm that's not as good as Roxy one
clearly not the engine dislikes 25 a lot
I'm surprised about that and maybe it
just it just puts the Queen into this
Knight c3 d5 business it's really
possible route dear one is good and now
we are p.m. yeah Katie fibers is a piece
he had to go innocent and back somehow
try to hold this position it does not
look good but it's not a full-piece
County I'm winning further pawns yeah I
think that was kind of okay that Bishop
takes the form move however that wasn't
a good decision it was better here to to
keep everything intact let's say and not
cash in with a with a pawn yeah this is
a very bad position I don't I don't even
see a movie the engine wants to do this
and can just give away the porn yeah and
this is kind of terrible it sits upon
upon down and no compensation whatsoever
and I still have things to attack the
night on b6 it's not stable as well yeah
that would have been quite a bit better
comparison okay well thanks for watching